il y a deux ans la famille d'isabelle la
voix attendaient impatiemment le procès
du présumé meurtrier de la jeune femme
c'est toujours reporté quelques matchs
que tu veux qu'on fasse notre deuil le
temps passe et le supplice continue le
procès devrait finalement commencer en
septembre
trois ans après le meurtre on commence à
sortir la tête de l'eau
on est originaire replonger latin
moi je trouve que la justice est pourrie
on taxe les abords qui mène les sables
l'avocat a remis rémy est encore là
encore c'est l'enfer pour la famille
le juge en chef de la cour supérieure
comprends l'indignation des victimes
mais après l'arrêt des procédures dont
trois présumés meurtriers ont bénéficié
dans l'année suivant l'arrêt jordin le
plus fort de la tempête serait passé
ottawa pour vu six des huit nouveaux
postes de juge à la cour supérieure
les postes vacants sont comblés trois
fois plus rapidement
québec paie des juges à la retraite pour
des conférences de règlement qui évite
la tenue d'un procès ce champ des
progrès et manche mais parce qu'on a eu
les ressources et parce que les jeux
jugés retravaillé très très franc
l'arrêt jordan limite la durée des
procédures judiciaires à 18 mois en cour
du québec et 30 mois en cour supérieure
depuis trois ans le délai médian a
diminué de plus de 20% en matière
criminelle au québec
pour les avocats la cadence est
exigeante
les procureurs sont sont essoufflés et
les procurent en vivent
je voudrais avec l'horloge du temps le
dpcp mise entre autres sur le
déploiement d'un programme de mesures de
rechange pour continuer à réduire les
délais je pense au programme de non
utilisation je pense au programme de
mesures de rechange par exemple ans au
dossier de santé mentale qui dans la
plupart des cas ne devrait pas se
retrouver devant un tribunal
donc on a encore beaucoup à faire
dessous de ce côté là et pour une
famille éplorée
ce sera toujours trop peu trop tard
sarine nous autres séries des victimes
ps mais c'est la bureaucratie beaucoup y
a des droits
maintenant mais mam il ya des droits le
droit d'aimer des temps comme si ici
genève garon radio canada montréal